je passe à l'article 1 bis trois
amendements identiques de suppression
d'abord le 124 madame poncet mange
merci monsieur le président face à
l'inflation donc l'urgence sociale
appelle des mesures fortes de
revalorisation des salaires afin de
permettre le maintien pérenne du pouvoir
d'achat cela passe notamment par la
nécessité d' accord de branche et
d'entreprise dynamique actant des
augmentations de salaires ainsi que par
l'augmentation du smic car comme
l'europe le souligne la dares en 2021
concernant la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
dans une trentaine de métiers en tension
l'apaisement des difficultés de
recrutement devra passer par je cite
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
la revalorisation des salaires dans
certains métiers plutôt que des réformes
de l'assurance chômage
en conséquence le retour de
l'attractivité de beaucoup de métiers et
de branches passe par des rémunérations
digne en plus de meilleures conditions
de travail mais le projet de loi on l'a
vu of plutôt les moyens d'éviter
l'augmentation des salaires en
encourageant les primes défiscaliser
désocialisés et alors en résonance avec
le gouvernement cet article ajoutées en
commission introduit une déduction
supplémentaires forfaitaire des
cotisations patronales pour les
entreprises à partir de 20 salariés
c'est-à-dire les plus grandes pas en
dessous à partir au titre des heures
supplémentaires poursuivant et
accélérant la fuite en avant de
réduction du salaire socialisé
générateur de droit or ce nouveau
dispositif d'exonération ne permet en
rien d'aider les salariés mais les
contraint à toujours travailler plus
pour maintenir un pouvoir d'achat en
régression tout en creusant toujours
plus les déficits publics c'est un
cercle vicieux pour le groupe écologiste
ni les salariés ni les comptes publics
ou les comptes de sécurité sociale ne
doivent servir de variable d'ajustement
face à la pression inflationniste
en conséquence nous proposons de
supprimer cet article additionnel je
vous remercie c'est le 156 qui le défend
monsieur guay
merci monsieur le président ce ministre
mes chers collègues
nous demandons également la suppression
de la défiscalisation et de la
désocialisation des heures
supplémentaires adoptées par notre
commission des finances surtout qu'on a
un précédent ça va vous faire plaisir
mes chers collègues est-ce que ça a été
instauré à appeler ou en 2008 par
nicolas sarkozy
et
évidemment on a des études
sur ces questions on a cité la dares le
fc eux aussi a fait une étude assez
intéressante je vous en lit quelques
passages elle a dit que ça va augmenter
le pouvoir d'achat
concrètement des salariés mais la
contrepartie ça surtout entraîné
l'allongement de la durée du travail
puis à deux questions je sais que vous
allez être servis puisque vous parlez
souvent de les comptes publics ça a
coûté aux comptes publics avec la baisse
des cotisations et l'exonération d'impôt
quatre milliards et demi
pas une petite question et puis en
termes d'emplois ça a été négatif
puisque seraient supprimés entre 53000
et 95 mille emplois en quatre ans donc
effet quasi nulles son pouvoir d'achat
en tout cas moins que le salaire khl et
puis en termes économiques et en terme
d'emploi le bilan est plutôt négatif
donc nous proposons de ne pas réitérer
cette expérience malheureuse
au nom du gouvernement le 454 monsieur
merci monsieur le président c'est le
deuxième amendement qui traduit une des
divergences entre le gouvernement et la
commission des affaires sociales du
sénat nous proposons de supprimer cet
article 1er bis qui prévoit une
déduction forfaitaire de cotisations
patronales sur les heures
supplémentaires
limiter un part forfaitaire et si j'ai
bien compris les auteurs d'amendements
en particulier sur les 25 % de
majoration le gouvernement considère que
ce n'est pas une mesure de pouvoir
d'achat que ça peut être éventuellement
une mesure de compétitivité
le ministre de l'économie a dit ce matin
être disponible pour voir si cette
mesure peut être circonscrite à
certaines entreprises et je considère
comme j'ai dit ce matin que cette mesure
relève plus du plfr que du projet doit
pouvoir d'achat dans la mesure où le
plfr qui vous sera soumis dans quelques
jours est aussi le texte qui permet
d'augmenter le plafond de 5500 euros
d'heures supplémentaires faisant l'objet
d'exonérations fiscales et sociales pour
les salariés donc c'est une demande de
retrait au bénéfice de cette discussion
ouverte avec la mise à l'économie
merci alors à vis de la commission je
considère à monsieur le ministre que
l'avis du gouvernement est évidemment
favorable aux amendements puisque trois
fois identique merci monsieur le
président alors effectivement c'est un
article 1er bis que nous avons introduit
en commission 1 dans l'objet vise à
réduire les cotisations patronales sur
la majoration de salaire au titre des
heures supplémentaires c'est important
de préciser alors simplement les uns les
autres nous rencontrons tous un certain
nombre de salariés on voit qu'il ya
beaucoup de salariés qui souhaitent
faire des heures supplémentaires soient
effectivement parce qu'ils ont envie de
les faire et c'est bien légitime mais
soit également parce qu'ils ont une
véritable difficulté de pouvoir d'achat
et ça rentre donc pleinement dans ce
texte et c'est plutôt vertueux comme
comme en tout cas comme comme besoin et
je trouve qu'il faudrait l'encourager
deuxièmement de rencontrer aussi des
employeurs qui peuvent être dans la
difficulté et en l'occurrence l'article
tel qu'il a été proposé vise à rejoindre
la solution pour ces deux difficultés
monsieur dit en ce qui concerne le coup
vous avez énoncés je rappelle simplement
que cet article d'abord et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure ne concerne que la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
donc on ne parle bien que des 25% pour
les entreprises de plus de 20 salariés
et de surcroît nous avons renvoyé le
montant de la rémunération par décret au
gouvernement donc on a bien entendu le
chiffre que nous avait annoncé mais on
est bien loin si selon effectivement les
discussions qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
des chiffres tels que ceux que vous avez
de vous nous avez que vous avez lancée
du type 4 milliards d'euros et enfin ce
qui concerne le fait de renvoyer cet
amendement au plf monsieur le ministre
simplement tout ce qui concerne les
cotisations sociales a toujours été
traités par la commission sociale et
dans le cadre du plfss donc il ya toute
légitimité pour que nous puissions
traiter cet amendement est en
l'occurrence est donc un avis
défavorable pour les trois amendements
monsieur le président puisque nous
souhaitons effectivement que cet article
demeure dans le texte
[Musique]